Prof: So you remember
Pasteur was very fond of racemic
and tartaric acid.
So when he'd travel around he
would look for samples of
tartaric acid.
There are very detailed
accounts that he published of
these travels.
I haven't found this one,
so I'm not sure it's true.
It may be apocryphal,
but it was told to me by the
guy who taught me organic
chemistry.
So I pass it onto you,
for what it's worth,
because it makes a good point.
He said that Pasteur was in
Alsace,
the wine-producing region in
northeast France,
and in the town of Thann he
found in a pharmacy a bottle of
racemic acid that was moldy.
So remember racemic acid's the
50:50 mixture.
So, since he liked racemic acid
-- and in fact it was becoming
rare.
It's a not a very common
product;
mostly you get the handed stuff.
So he took it back and cleaned
it up, got rid of the mold that
was growing on it.
And what he found was that
after he had purified it,
it was the unnatural,
the left-handed,
not the one you normally get.
Can you see an explanation for
that?
Had the apothecary mislabeled
it because he thought he could
get a higher price for racemic
than for tartaric acid?
Or might he have been innocent?
Zack?
Student:  Was it the
mold by any chance?
Prof: What did the mold
do?
Student:  Might have
converted one into all.
Prof: Didn't convert.
Student:  It didn't?
Prof: The mold ate the
natural stuff,
converted it into something
completely different,
leaving the unnatural one.
Okay?
Remember the smell of the
carvones?
Natural things,
enzymes and so on,
can distinguish between the two
hands,
and naturally the stuff that
normally eats tartaric acid is
going to eat normal tartaric
acid,
not the unusual one.
So it left the unusual one.
The penicillium glaucum
had eaten the R,R.
Okay, so that's one way of
doing resolution,
to get rid of one enantiomer
from a racemic mixture,
leaving the other one,
because diastereomeric
reactions have different rates.
It's a right hand shaking a
right hand versus a right hand
shaking a left hand;
they're just different.
So one will go faster than the
other.
So if you react a racemate with
some chiral reagent --
of course you have to use only
one hand of that other thing you
add in there --
but then you'll react with one
more than the other.
It could be even a catalyst so
that it doesn't get consumed;
an enzyme, for example.
But that's not Nature's way,
because it's very inefficient
to make both and then destroy
one.
What nature does is prepare
only one enantiomer.
And you can do that,
prepare only one,
by starting with something
that's already a single
enantiomer and building on that.
Or you can use a reagent,
which is resolved,
that will -- because
diastereomeric rates are
different --
will tend to produce one of the
two enantiomers.
So here's an example of this
molecule we've been talking
about,
Eisai-7389, with its nineteen
asymmetric centers,
that's made artificially,
commercially.
And this is where those
nineteen centers came from.
Five of them came from starting
materials that they bought as a
single hand.
But the rest were all made.
One of them was done by
chromatography.
They have chromatography
columns about this big around,
and this high,
with chiral stuff inside.
So you pass your thing through.
One hand goes through a little
faster than the other,
because of its diastereomeric
interaction with the packing;
one comes through quicker.
And they actually do that for
one of the centers.
But the others are all done by
reactions that preferentially
give one center rather than the
other.
Three of them are ones that
everybody knew which one they
would give.
The other ones they just had to
hope, and fiddle around with
different reactions until they
found one that would do the
trick.
So anyhow, they were able to
generate these nineteen
stereocenters.
Now we're left with a problem.
That incidentally is all we're
going to have for the exam on
Friday.
Okay?
So now we're on to other stuff
that will be covered on the
final exam, and in particular
return to this question about
the tartaric acids.
Remember there's d-(+)
and l-(-).
Could you have l-(+) and
d-(-),
of a different compound?
Why not?
What does d or l
mean, in this context?
Student:
>.
Prof: Andrew?
Student:  It reflects
light to the left.
Prof: It means which way
it rotates the light.
Right?
And the plus means the same
thing, as d.
So it's redundant,
this particular nomenclature.
But there's a question mark
because when -- Fischer just
guessed, remember?
And it could easily have been
the opposite.
So which way is it?
Right?
So if we knew,
if we knew how optical activity
worked, then by measuring the
optical activity we'd know which
of those structures is right.
Okay?
But we don't know that;
at least I don't know that.
Now there's a lot of knowledge
about this, but it's a very,
very tough problem.
Fortunately there's a book by
Laurence Barron called
Molecular Light Scattering
and Optical Activity,
which goes into this stuff.
And I see Professor Vaccaro --
Prof: I'm here.
Prof: Oh,
so we have a copy of the book.
That's great.
But even better than that,
we have Laurence Barron.
Prof: Or a copy of
Laurence Barron.
>
Perhaps it's the mirror image
of Laurence Barron.
So he's going to tell us how
this works.
<<Technical
instructions>>
Prof: Well good morning
everybody.
I was both delighted and
dismayed, at the same time,
when Professor McBride asked me
to try and -- well to address
you this morning.
Delighted to have the
opportunity to talk science to
some of America's brightest
budding young scientists,
but also dismayed that he asked
me to try and explain the
molecular origin of optical
rotation,
optical activity.
It's a very subtle,
difficult, delicate problem,
that's exercised some of the
finest minds in physics and
chemistry for the last hundred
years.
But anyway, let's see how it
goes.
Towards the end I think I may
be presenting some stuff that's
sort of beyond the boundaries of
your current knowledge.
But anyway, it can at least
pass in front of your eyes.
So chirality then means,
as you well know,
right- or left-handedness.
It pervades much of modern
science;
from the physics of elementary
particles, through organic
stereochemistry,
to the structure and behavior
of the molecules of life;
with a lot more besides.
It comes up in what's called
nonlinear optics,
involving intense lasers;
nanotechnology;
materials, electrical
engineering;
pharmaceuticals;
astrobiology;
and origin of life.
So it's a very important theme
in modern science.
Now first of all though I'll
tell you a little bit about Lord
Kelvin.
He was the first person to
introduce the word
chirality into science.
He was professor of natural
philosophy in Glasgow -- which
is my home university -- through
most of his career;
well all of his career.
He was one of the giants of
physics of the nineteenth
century.
He's best known for inventing
the absolute Kelvin temperature
scale.
Now he was originally,
his original name was William
Thomson, but then he became
famous and became Sir William
Thomson.
Then he became even more
famous, so they made him a Lord.
And when you're made a Lord in
the U.K., you choose your title
from someplace that's dear to
your heart, maybe your home
area.
He took his title from the name
of the River Kelvin,
which runs through the
University Park in Glasgow.
So whenever you use the
absolute temperature scale now
in the future,
you can picture this idyllic
scene.
Anyway, so he was the first to
introduce the word
chirality into science.
And here's his definition,
which you'll be familiar with:
"I call any geometrical
figure or group of points
chiral,
and say that it has chirality
if its image in a plane mirror,
ideally realized,
cannot be brought into
coincidence with itself."
That was in his Baltimore
Lectures.
So he's just emphasizing the
non-superimposabity of the
mirror image,
the enantiomers of a chiral
molecule.
But of course the whole subject
started earlier with the
wonderful work of Louis Pasteur,
who showed mirror-image chiral
molecules show optical rotation
of equal magnitude but opposite
sign;
which was an epoch-making
discovery.
So you've come across then
this, the fundamental
manifestation of optical
activity, which is natural
optical rotation.
You put linearly polarized
light beam into a sample --
say a sample of an isotropic
collection of chiral molecules,
like a sugar solution -- and it
will come out the other side
with the plane of polarization
rotated through some angle.
And if you put in the mirror
image version,
you'll get an equal but
opposite sense of optical
rotation.
Now it's not to be confused
with something called magnetic
optical rotation,
the Faraday effect.
I'm just mentioning this to you.
You probably haven't come
across the Faraday effect yet,
but you may do later on in your
studies, or in your professional
life.
So I'll mention the Faraday
effect.
Faraday discovered,
in 1846, that achiral samples
--
no natural optical activity
there --
if you apply a static magnetic
field,
parallel to the light beam,
that will induce an optical
rotation.
And if you put in -- if you
reverse the direction of the
magnetic field,
relative to the light beam,
you'll get an equal and
opposite sense of optical
rotation.
It would even work say for a
sample of water,
for instance.
Any material will show a
Faraday effect.
But this has been a source of
much confusion,
in fact, to scientists.
Now Lord Kelvin was on the ball
here.
He knew all about it.
He made a statement here.
He said, "The magnetic
rotation has neither
right-handed nor left-handed
quality."
(That is to say no chirality;
it's got nothing to do with
chirality.)
"This was perfectly
understood by Faraday and made
clear in his writings,
yet even to the present day we
frequently find the chiral
rotation and the magnetic
rotation of the plane of
polarization classed together in
a manner against which Faraday's
original description contains
ample warning."
Well Lord Kelvin would be
turning in his grave today,
100 years later,
because you still see papers
which involve the Faraday
effect,
in some way or other,
and in the introduction they
talk grandly of "inducing
chirality with a magnetic
field."
That is completely wrong.
Just for the record -- probably
beyond your knowledge at the
moment --
chiral phenomena,
like natural optical rotation,
they're characterized by what's
called time-even pseudoscalar
observables.
A pseudoscalar is a number that
changes sign under reflection or
inversion;
we'll leave it at that.
So that's for the record.
But well it turns out the
essential symmetry
characteristics of natural and
magnetic optical rotation are
completely different and you
need different sorts of
molecular quantum states,
different characteristics to
support them.
But we won't pursue that.
Right, now back to natural
optical rotation.
So now we bring in circularly
polarized light.
So in order to detect molecular
chirality, you must have some
sort of chiral probe.
Well what we're using here is
right and left-circularly
polarized light beams.
They are actually mirror-image
chiral systems.
So they can be used as chiral
probes.
So here's a representation of a
right-circularly polarized light
beam.
Now you know that light
involves electromagnetic
oscillations in space,
and usually you just think of
the oscillating electric vector
of a light wave,
and if it's linearly polarized,
it's oscillating in one plane.
There's actually also an
oscillating magnetic field
vector that oscillates
perpendicular to the electric.
We'll come back to that later.
We're just looking at the
oscillating electric vector
here.
So if it's linearly polarized,
or plane polarized,
it's just oscillating in a
plane;
but circularly polarized light,
as well as an oscillation in
this direction.
You also have an electric
vector oscillating perpendicular
but 90° out of phase.
And what happens is you get
this circular polarization.
Now this picture here,
this represents the
instantaneous electric vectors
at different points in space,
in the direction of
propagation, along the z
direction.
And so here we are,
that's just showing -- that's
just connected the ends of the
instantaneous electric vectors.
And there it is for
left-circularly polarized.
Anyway, you can see that at the
very least those are chiral,
those are helical,
and those are mirror-image
chiral systems.
Now here we go.
This is some extra fancy stuff
that Professor McBride added to
my >
presentation.
He doesn't like -- it was too
simple and static.
Anyway, so there we are.
So now if you look at the wave,
if you just look at the
electric vector through --
in a fixed plane,
as the light wave is
propagating,
there's the electric vector,
and it will rotate in the fixed
plane.
So rotating clockwise,
that defines right-circularly
polarized light.
And here we go,
rotating counter-clockwise;
that's left-circularly
polarized light.
Okay, so we now have a chiral
optical probe,
circularly polarized light.
Now chiral molecules respond
slightly differently to right
and left-circularly polarized
light.
I mean, an extreme example is
say in the world of engineering.
You can't fit a left-handed nut
onto a right-handed bolt.
That's an extreme example of
different chiral interactions.
Well it's obviously much more
delicate than that here.
But the point is right and
left-circularly polarized light
interact just slightly
differently with a molecule of a
given chirality.
Anyway, there's a differential
absorption of right and
left-circularly polarized light.
That corresponds to a
phenomenon called circular
dichroism, which is the basis of
a widely used form of
spectroscopy used to study
chiral molecules.
But now, what gives rise to
optical rotation is a difference
in refractive index towards --
of right and left-circularly
polarized light beams.
Now linearly polarized light,
you can describe it as a
coherent superposition of right
and left-circularly polarized
waves of equal amplitude.
Coherent means they're in-phase
with each other.
Rather than being random,
they're oscillating in-phase
with some fixed phase
relationship.
So, for example,
now here's a linearly polarized
light beam.
But you can decompose it into a
superposition of a left-circular
and a right-circular component.
You see when those are at the
top they're reinforcing,
and you've got the maximum
linearly polarized vector up
here.
As they come away,
left and right,
they will tend to increasingly
cancel, and that will decrease.
And when they're this way and
this way, you'll have zero
electric field vector there,
and as you come down it will
increase again.
So you can decompose a linearly
polarized light into a coherent
superposition of left and right
waves.
Now, refractive index
corresponds to velocity through
a medium.
So if there's a difference in
refractive index for right and
left-circularly polarized light
beams,
that means there's a slight
difference in the velocity of
the right and left-circularly
polarized light beams going
through the medium.
So the phase relations between
the two contrarotating electric
vectors will change.
And you can easily see,
this will give you a rotation
in the plane of polarization.
You see, if there's a
difference in velocity,
then at some instant this
vector, this electric vectors of
the left component will be here,
and the right component here.
And if you take the resultant,
you see, it's no longer where
it was.
So this is a simple picture of
how optical rotation develops,
in terms of different
refractive indices of the right
and left components.
Now there's a picture in
Atkins' Physical
Chemistry.
He tries to illustrate this
there.
He's got the linearly polarized
beam coming through,
and you've got the -- he's
broken it down into the left and
right,
and he's saying the two
velocities are slightly
different,
and that gives you the
resultant optical rotation.
You can easily develop an
expression for the angle of
rotation as a function of the
difference in refractive indices
for left and right-circularly
polarized light beams.
And it's also -- it's a
function of the path length.
Obviously the longer the path
length, the more rotation will
develop.
And there's the wavelength
there in the denominator.
In fact, I mean,
this is the secret;
this path length,
that's the secret of how you
get a measurable rotation.
Because this is an incredibly
tiny effect.
If it was just a single
molecule event you're looking
at, the polarization changes,
you wouldn't see anything,
they're so tiny.
But you can build up this
rotation over long path lengths,
centimeters or even meters.
In fact, if you go to Google,
Google Images,
and just Google 'circularly
polarized light,' you'll find
lots of sites there which
describe polarized light,
and they provide beautiful
simulations,
animations of this effect here.
I didn't want to download any
and try and show them here,
but I would encourage you to go
to that.
But go and look in particular
at this site here,
enzim.hu.
That comes from an institute of
enzymology in Budapest.
They've got some beautiful
simulations of this optical
rotation process and other more
exotic polarization effects,
as light propagates through
matter.
Now, let's try and -- so that's
just, what would you say,
a phenomenological description.
And in fact that's where most
physical chemistry textbooks
stop.
And in fact Atkins' Physical
Chemistry stops at that
point,
and then just there's just sort
of hand waving saying okay,
right and left-circularly
polarized light interacts
slightly differently with the
chiral molecule;
and they leave it at that.
They don't attempt to try and
give you a picture in molecular
detail.
But Professor McBride wanted me
to try and attempt this.
So just as a start,
this is a simple picture,
a simple scattering picture of
optical rotation.
Now a circularly polarized
light wave 'bouncing' from one
group to the other,
as it scatters from a simple
two-group chiral structure,
will sample the chirality.
So here we have a simple
two-group chiral molecular
structure.
So we've got two achiral
groups, held in a rigid,
twisted arrangement.
I think that's left-handed I've
got there.
And you can break down -- if
you look at most chiral
molecules, just look at the
bonds, you can often break them
down.
You can see these sorts of
two-group structures throughout.
Anyway, so a particular model
of optical rotation is that the
light wave,
it bounces from one group to
the other,
before coming off and getting
involved in generating the
optical rotation phenomenon.
But you can see,
it's sampling the chirality as
it bounces from one to the
other.
So if the light beam is
right-circularly polarized,
that bouncing process will have
a slightly different amplitude,
as we say, from if it's
left-circularly polarized.
So that gives you a simple
picture.
It's worth mentioning that this
is the basis of something called
the "dynamic coupling model
of optical activity"
that was developed by somebody
called John Kirkwood,
who was chairman of this
department in the 1950s.
Well now we really have to
>
, we have to grasp the nettle
at this point,
because you just -- it's
hopeless messing around with
these simple models.
>
They don't get you anywhere as
regards prediction;
you know, relating structure to
sign and magnitude of optical
activity.
You have to go to the
quantum-mechanics.
So now this was the expression
for the optical rotation,
in terms of the refractive
index difference for left and
right-circularly polarized
light.
Now you can develop this using
something called
quantum-mechanical perturbation
theory,
and you develop an expression
for the rotation angle in terms
of this incomprehensible looking
stuff.
But let me just try and give
you a feel for what it's telling
us.
The heart of it is this
so-called rotational strength,
which involves this so-called
scalar product of an electric
dipole and a magnetic dipole
transition moment.
So what we've got here is
there's the ground state of the
molecule n;
j is some excited
electronic state;
and μ is the electric
dipole operator that's
connecting the ground to the
excited state.
And the light wave is
interacting, is coupling with
this electric dipole operator,
and it's driving the
transition.
And it's this -- these electric
dipole transitions,
like this, that's behind
conventional spectroscopy.
You've done probably UV and
infrared spectroscopy.
But now what we have in
addition is the same transition,
but now brought about through
m;
that's called a magnetic dipole
operator, and that's activated
by this oscillating magnetic
component of the light wave.
And so you have this so-called
scalar product.
So μ•m,
that would be μ_xm_x +
μ_ym_y + μ_zn_z.
Some of you have probably done
vectors.
Maybe others haven't.
But okay.
So that's the heart of it.
But this is a very important
feature here.
We're summing over all excited
states, j,
all excited states.
So the whole plethora of
excited states of a chiral
molecule come in here,
and some can give you -- one
particular excited state can
give you a positive contribution
to the optical rotation;
another one a negative.
You know?
So it's a very subtle problem,
and you have to consider them
all carefully.
So optical activity ultimately
originates in interference
between electric and magnetic
dipole transitions during the
light scattering process.
That's at the heart of it.
Now, let me just show you how
this works out.
I can now give you a chemical,
an interpretation,
in terms of a real and highly
important system in organic
chemistry: the carbonyl
chromophore.
I believe you have come across
the carbonyl chromophore.
A lot of important organic
molecules contain this carbonyl
chromophore.
It gives rise to a transition
in the near ultraviolet at about
290 nanometers,
and it's widely used in
physical organic chemistry.
It's called the n to
π* transition.
Now the carbonyl group itself
-- here it is -- that's not
chiral, that's got a plane of
symmetry.
So by itself it's not going --
there's going to be no optical
activity there.
But you see,
in this particular molecule
here, 3-methylcyclohexanone,
that molecule overall is
chiral.
There's a chiral center there.
So that carbonyl group is
experiencing a chiral
perturbation,
a through space perturbation
from the rest of the chiral
molecule,
and that induces chirality into
the electronic transitions of
the carbonyl group,
and induces optical rotation
and circular dichroism.
Well let's look at this in a
bit more detail,
this famous n to
π* transition.
So here we've got the
σ bonding orbital
of the carbonyl group.
There's the π bonding
orbital, made up of two -- of
the pπ on carbon and
on oxygen.
And here is a lone -- sorry,
here is a py orbital.
So those are px orbitals.
That's the py orbital on
the oxygen.
Feed electrons in,
and so you've got,
in the ground state,
you've got two there,
two there.
And you've got two electrons in
the py orbital.
So those are lone-pair
electrons.
So the lowest order,
the lowest transition now is
the py to π*,
often called the n to
π* transition.
You're promoting one electron
from the py orbital up to
the π* orbital;
and that's the origin of this
transition.
Well let's -- ah now.
Okay, now this transition,
it happens to be fully magnetic
dipole-allowed but completely
electric dipole-forbidden.
What happens is electric dipole
character is induced by mixing
--
well I'm giving the example of
a higher oxygen dyz_
orbital into the
π* orbital.
Now Professor McBride has been
messing around with my
presentation here.
Let's see what he's done.
So here's the n orbital,
the py orbital of the
carbonyl group.
There's the π*.
Ah, now here we go.
So this is now -- but wait --
yeah,
so here you can see,
in that n to
π* transition,
there's a net rotation of
charge, a rotation of charge.
And that's the essence of the
magnetic dipole-allowed
character.
Magnetic dipole transitions
involve a rotation of charge.
Prof: And the reason we
messed about with them in this
way is we've seen the mixing
p orbitals changing the
orientation,
causing them to rotate that way.
Prof: Right.
So what's -- ah okay,
now here we go again.
Now here's a dyz orbital.
Now one could consider a whole
loads of other possible orbitals
to mix in.
But this is the simplest one,
just to illustrate the idea
here.
So there's a dyz orbital.
Now going from -- you see
n to dyz,
if you add those orbitals
together,
you tend to get a displacement
of charge in the z
direction.
So now, you see,
you have a combination of a
rotation of charge with a
displacement of charge,
and rotation plus translation
gives helicity.
And here we go.
There.
So by mixing in a little bit of
this dxz orbital,
you get this -- which is
electric dipole-allowed -- you
get this helicity in the
transition.
Now, in fact,
the rotation of charge
generates a magnetic dipole
perpendicular to the plane of
rotation, and it's pointing that
way.
So you'll get an m_z
component, a component of the
magnetic moment along the
z axis.
Here you can see immediately
you've got a component of the
electric dipole along the
z axis.
So that generates a
μ_zm_z component,
from this scalar product of
μ and m,
in the rotational strength.
So this is sort of making a
meal of it here now.
So we're just putting down
these so-called
quantum-mechanical matrix
elements.
So here we've got n to
π*,
with a little bit of that mixed
in, and that's fully magnetic
dipole-allowed.
Then we have n to
π*,
which is forbidden electric
dipole,
but mixing that in gives you a
little bit of electric dipole
character.
And so you now get a non-zero
contribution to the rotational
strength.
However, you wouldn't want to
go on and actually calculate the
optical rotation of the carbonyl
chromophore, in some situation
from this.
Because, as I said,
there's many other excited
electronic states you could have
also considered,
which may be giving opposite
contributions to the rotational
strength.
You have to sum them all,
and to do that you now have to
go to modern ab initio
quantum-chemistry,
quantum-chemical calculations.
There's wonderful programs out
now, from Gaussian and Dalton;
you can calculate all sorts of
molecular properties,
with quite good -- very good
accuracy, in many cases.
But this now turns it all into
a black box procedure.
You just feed in appropriate
atomic orbitals and press
buttons and turn handles,
whatever you do for these
calculations,
and out will pop some physical
quantity.
So you can calculate this whole
thing, ab initio,
and taking in however many
excited states in the sum are
necessary.
And you can calculate the sign
and magnitude of the optical
rotation, for a given absolute
configuration.
So you would feed into the
calculation whether it's the
S or the R
absolute stereochemistry.
So you'd put that in,
and that will determine the
sign of the optical rotation
that comes out.
And so -- I mean,
in this particular case,
this small molecule,
the S absolute
configuration,
goes with the plus rotation and
the R goes with the
minus.
So from the calculation then
you can relate the sign of the
optical rotation to the absolute
stereochemistry.
But you wouldn't want to stake
your life on it,
because it's not completely
reliable.
It usually gives the right
answer, for smaller molecules,
but not always.
And, for example,
if this was -- as you know,
and I think you'll hear more
after my talk here.
Many drugs now are chiral,
and drug companies like to
market now single enantiomer
versions of the drug.
So it's a tremendously
important problem for them to
know,
with absolute certainty,
the absolute configuration of
the particular enantiomer
they're marketing,
because if they make a mistake
and specify the wrong absolute
configuration in their patent,
they can literally lose
billions of dollars.
Anyway, there's the famous --
the importance of chirality in
drugs is exemplified by the
famous thalidomide case.
But I won't elaborate that any
more.
I think Professor McBride is
going to tell you some more of
that in more detail.
I should say that the
cornerstone, the definitive
method for determining absolute
configuration has,
for some years now,
been something called the
Bijvoet method of anomalous
X-ray scattering,
which again Professor -- have
you told them about that?
Prof: Yes.
Prof: Yeah.
Yeah, that's the definitive
method.
But it's sort of cheating
because you're actually seeing
-- you're seeing it through
X-ray eyes.
But even then,
you can occasionally make a
mistake.
But I should just mention also,
there are some newer optical
activity techniques involving
something called vibrational
optical activity.
Here we've been looking at
optical activity in electronic
transitions, using visible
light.
But in recent years newer
methods, measuring optical
activity in vibrational
transitions, have come along.
And these are actually
comparable with X-ray,
anomalous X-ray scattering,
for reliability of absolute
configuration.
That's because these
calculations are much more
reliable for these vibrational
optical activity phenomena than
electronic ones.
Well that's about it.
That's all I would like to say
now.
So thank you for listening.
>
Prof: Now that you've
heard from the authority,
do you have any questions about
it?
You are unwontedly quiet,
like you usually are.
Any questions?
Yes?
Prof: I'm just wondering
if the magnitude of the Faraday
rotation can ever interfere with
the measurement of optical
rotation in the chiral material?
That is to say,
if one situates a polarimeter
in proximity to an NMR
spectrometer,
for example?
Prof: No.
No, you wouldn't need to worry
about that at all.
No.
You need a reasonable strength
of magnetic fields just applied
directly through the sample.
Yeah.
Prof: Lucas?
Student:  Just if I'm
understanding.
The n to π* is
magnetically dipole-allowed,
electric dipole-forbidden,
and that's why then it goes to
the xz as well,
in order to get the electric
dipole…
Prof: The electric,
yeah.
Student:  …in
there, that contribution.
Prof: Yes.
Student:  For my
knowledge.
>
Prof: Okay,
thanks again Laurence.
Prof: My pleasure.
Prof: Very good.
>
Prof: Thank you.
Laurence Barron:  Okay.
Prof: So yeah,
this is just a plug.
This afternoon -- the reason
Professor Barron is here is he's
the Tetelman lecturer in
Jonathan Edwards College.
So he's giving a talk for the
history majors and so on.
But it'll be very interesting
for anyone.
And I think since we're into
chirality, you would enjoy this,
particularly this afternoon,
in Davies Auditorium at 5:00.
But there's the question,
who cares?
No offense.
But who cares?
Why do we care about chirality?
Well Professor Barron hinted at
it.
Living things care,
because they're chiral.
Right?
So which one they react with.
Okay?
The Food and Drug
Administration cares,
for the same reason,
with respect to medications you
might be taking.
Drug companies care a lot,
and their lawyers.
And the US Patent Office cares
a lot.
Right?
Which has generated a thing
called a "chiral
switch."
Most drugs that used to be
developed were developed as
racemates, because it was
difficult to separate the two
hands.
But if your patent runs out on
the racemate,
and you can resolve it and now
sell just one of them,
and if it's better,
and the FDA will approve it,
and you can convince people
that that's the one they should
buy,
then you can go back to not
having to compete with generic
drug companies anymore and
charge five dollars a pill
instead of fifty cents a pill.
Okay?
So this so-called chiral
switch, to go from racemic to a
single enantiomer,
is a big movement nowadays.
For example,
consider this pain reliever.
Let's figure out what it is.
Do you remember what that group
is: four carbons,
in that sort of Mercedes
structure?
Do you know what that group's
called?
This, what we're doing for the
rest of the lecture here out is
actually review for the exam on
Friday.
You're not specifically
responsible for it,
but it's review.
So you know that group?
Student:  Isobutyl.
Prof: Isobutyl.
Okay, and what acid is that,
with three carbons,
do you know?
The first fatty acid?
Student:  Propionic.
Prof: Propionic acid.
And in the middle we have --
Student:  Phenol?
Prof: Phenyl group.
Okay?
So what's the name of the drug?
Student:  Ibuprofen.
Prof: Sherwin?
Prof: Ibu-pro-fen.
Advil or Motrin.
Okay, now in this case you have
a chiral center there -- right?
-- because there's a hydrogen
on there that we don't see.
And the S-form is a pain
reliever;
it's said to be so anyhow.
And the R is inactive.
Right?
But it's marketed as a racemate.
One might try doing a chiral
switch and selling only the
S.
But the trouble is that it very
quickly racemizes inside you.
So it wouldn't be doing any
good, right?
Because you'd do all the work
of selling the S and then
it would become R
immediately, when you ate it.
And here's another one.
This is the one that Professor
Barron referred to,
which is a sedative;
thalidomide.
And there's the chiral center
in that one, because there's an
H on there.
So the S-form is a
sedative, but the R-form,
at least it's said,
is a teratogen;
which means it makes monsters.
>
And it's not so funny,
because it was sold as a
racemate from 1957 to '62 --
never in the U.S.
because the FDA didn't -- they
were lucky and never approved
it.
But in Europe it caused 10,000
birth defects;
children born without arms,
legs, things like that.
So it was a tragedy.
But this one also undergoes
in vivo racemization.
Okay?
You can find rate constants for
these.
It's curious that the rate of
S going to R,
and the rate of R going
to S, are not the same.
There's got to be more to it
than that, that one has to be
more stable than the other,
of these mirror images;
if that's true.
It may be that the rates aren't
exactly true.
But if so, they must be bound
to something that makes --
that's chiral -- that makes one
of them more stable than the
other.
Anyhow, that's how fast they go
back and forth.
And this is how fast they get
eliminated from the body;
one gets eliminated much faster
than the other.
And if you put these things
together, you can see how the
concentration should vary with
time, if it's going according to
that rate.
So the blue one,
the one that's good for you,
quickly drops off.
The bad one,
the teratogen,
grows quickly.
So you have maybe two hours of
twenty-four hours where you got
a lot more of the good one than
the bad one.
So essentially this drug is
completely off-limits,
especially for any women that
could conceivably,
under any circumstances,
be pregnant.
Okay?
So but it's a wonderful drug
for things like leprosy and so
on.
David here is an MD,
as well as a professor of
chemistry, and you probably know
more about that.
But it's a wonderful drug for
certain things.
Isn't that right?
Prof: That's right,
that's right.
It's still actually in common
usage for anxiety disorders.
Prof: Yeah,
but there are all sorts of
warnings,
in letters this big,
about if you have a chance of
getting pregnant,
stay away from this baby.
Right?
Prof: In fact,
if you're a male patient taking
it,
and your wife is pregnant or
likely to become pregnant,
you're encouraged not to take
it.
Prof: Wow.
Prof: Because of
possible contamination.
Prof: Wow.
Okay, so now here's a drug.
We're going to look at the name
of this one.
It's a really whopper of a
name, right?
So let's just use this as a
practice about nomenclature.
Okay, so that thing there is
called imidazole,
and the 1H tells where
-- which one has a hydrogen on
it.
Right?
Okay, so that's position one.
And that is the benzene ring;
so benz.
So it's benzimidazole,
that group on the right.
And you number it.
Remember it was 1H;
there's an H on the nitrogen
one there.
And you go around the ring and
number in that conventional way.
Okay, now but then you notice
that there's something on the
number five, and there's
something on the number two
carbon of that ring.
On five, there's a methoxy
group, which appears first among
all the things in this -- named
here;
not the thing that's on two.
Why is the methoxy group first?
Do you remember what the rule
is?
Student:
>.
Prof: How do you arrange
the substituent groups?
Angela?
Student:  Alphabetically.
Prof: Alphabetically;
m is going to be the first one.
Okay, so 5-methoxy,
and then two is sulfinyl;
that S with an O on it is
called sulfinyl group.
Okay, so it's 2-sulfinyl.
But now there are all sorts of
curly brackets and square
brackets and so on,
to tell what's attached to
that.
Okay, so attached to that is
methyl group;
the methyl is substituted.
So it's methyl sulfinyl.
Okay, that's the curly -- the
square brackets.
Okay, now what's on the methyl?
There's a pyridine group;
the benzene with a nitrogen,
is pyridine.
And it's substituted on the
methyl at its own two position;
the two position of the
pyridine is what's attached to
the methyl.
So it's 2-pyridinyl, the end.
But now on that,
in the four position,
is methoxy.
And methoxy comes
alphabetically before methyl;
not before d,
but before methyl,
and you don't count the di.
Right?
So there's the name of that
compound.
And this stuff is a drug.
It's a gastric proton pump
inhibitor.
So it treats acid reflux
disease.
And it's the world's largest
selling drug in the Year 2000;
6.2 billion dollars.
And it's called omeprazole,
or Prilosec.
And you've seen probably,
some of you at least,
have seen boxes of Prilosec.
I hope you don't have to take
it, like I do occasionally.
This is called OTC.
We're going to be talking about
that on Monday.
Okay, so there it is.
Now get your glasses up.
Because can you see this?
Can you see any sort of
three-dimensions here?
What's in front,
or what's behind?
Can anybody tell?
You have any luck in seeing it
in three-dimensions?
Some people can't see it,
but most of you,
about 95% of you,
should be able to see.
It's not a really high quality
three-dimensions.
And because the computer -- the
projector doesn't do it exactly
right, for the colors.
So one eye sees only one and
one sees only the other.
Anybody see?
Okay, now what is chiral here?
Can you see why this thing is
chiral?
There's no carbon with four
different things on it.
But what makes it handed?
Can you see?
In fact, there's no group that
has four different things on it.
Any suggestions?
Lucas?
Student:  Sulfur.
Prof: Sulfur.
Sulfur has an unshared pair,
an oxygen, and two different R
groups.
And which is pointing out
toward you?
Can you see it enough in
three-dimensions,
with the glasses,
to see that,
to see which is pointing out?
Student:  The unshared
pair.
Prof: Yeah,
it's the unshared pair that's
pointing out.
So if you use your thumbs and
recognize that the unshared pair
has the lowest atomic number --
zero, right?
-- then you can do it.
And you'll find out that that
particular one drawn there is
the S enantiomer.
Okay?
So it's known -- omeprazole,
Prilosec, Prilosec OTC,
are the racemate.
But this one that's drawn here
is the S isomer,
and it's called what?
Esomeprazole;
that's the name of it, right?
Or Nexium.
Right?
And it's the S isomer,
right?
So this is the product of one
of these chiral switches,
where for a long time the stuff
was marketed as a racemate and
now they market it as a single
enantiomer, Nexium.
And we tried this one last
time, so we're not going to
spend time on it right now.
That's what the class looks
like when they're doing this.
It's fun for me to see you.
>
Okay?
But there are other ways of
doing the stereoviewing.
You can use a pair of
periscopes, like this.
Right?
And the way that works of
course -- well the point is,
for each eye to see a different
image.
So if you want to try those and
look at this after class,
feel free.
Or borrow them if you wish.
Right?
So what the eyes perceive is a
superposition in the middle.
It's like this.
There are two pictures.
But if you can do it with the
glasses, you can do it probably
just by looking at this picture,
if you have a little while.
But we don't have the little
while now.
The right eye will see that,
the left eye will see that,
and you see,
in the middle -- there see,
something in the same position
but in slightly different
projections.
So the image in the middle of
the three seems to be in 3-D.
Okay.
Now we don't have time to go --
we're going to do a lot of
curved arrow stuff,
about how reactions happen in
making omeprazole;
and then, even more
interesting, in the action of
omeprazole that stops the
stomach acid.
But we'll have to wait 'til
after the exam for that.
Okay?
Thanks again to Professor
Barron.
>